thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
good evening welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored with me Rosanna Lockwood now
on tonight's show as Hollywood turns the
story of Oppenheimer into a
popcorn-fleasing meme friendly box
office smash Russia threatens Ukraine
with a real nuclear bomb we'll debate if
it's time for the West to take
Armageddon a little more seriously
Elon musk's Rebrand of Twitter has taken
another set back he has been forced to
take his giant X down off the corporate
HQ over there in San Francisco does the
richest man in the world actually know
what he's doing at this point and as the
media rages about a cartoon drawing of a
transgender man on a Costa van I will be
asking isn't this all a bit of a storm
in a coffee cup
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood good evening welcome to
Piers Morgan I'm Santa with me Rosanna
Lockwood and the chef appears again
tonight the magic of the movies nothing
quite like them in terms of escapism but
what if a movie isn't so much of an
escape as a giant air raid siren now I'm
not talking about Barbie peers covered
that comprehensively last week of course
I'm talking about Oppenheimer The
Summer's other big Blockbuster about the
development of the first nuclear weapons
and look it's a great film great acting
great soundtrack but it's not an escape
I don't think because it's real
I came out of the cinema on Sunday after
watching it to news that Russian
officials are once again threatening to
use a nuclear weapon if Ukraine's
counter-offensive succeeds and that is
just the latest in a series of similar
threats they've been making and have you
been aware of that is that a story
you've seen discuss much in the news as
much as say arguments about language and
gender and ideology or the latest
celebrity presenter Scandal what if I
told you that just last month Putin said
Russia has moved their first batch of
nuclear weapons to Belarus and is saying
the rest will be transferred quote by
the end of the summer or the end of the
year a man with a plan would you then be
still so focused on the latest work
corporate advertising stunt
this is actually an information Warfare
tactic that is favored by the Kremlin
provoking hysteria and cultural debate
in other countries to sow Division and
confusion you could actually call it a
weapon of mass distraction and I'm not
saying the kremlin's been behind the
latest Costa Coffee ad or the latest Bud
Light commercial and I think we're doing
that ourselves I'm also not saying that
issues of ideology shouldn't be
carefully debated in our societies but I
am saying that we need to get some
perspective and spot when our eye is
dangerously off the ball there is an
estimated 12 and a half thousand nuclear
warheads in the world Russia's got
almost half of those and they're telling
us they might actually use some of them
but we're not really listening maybe if
we were Japanese we would be because
they take the issue of nuclear war far
more seriously because they know it a
reminder that in 1945 that's just 77
years ago the US detonated two atomic
bombs over two Japanese cities Hiroshima
and Nagasaki killing its estimated
anywhere up to a quarter of a million
people it was the first and so far only
wartime use of nuclear weapons in
history so it is no wonder the Japanese
reception of the American made on
Oppenheimer movie has been so sensitive
the movie is a terrifying summary of
what happens when we leave the power of
Godlike destruction in the hands of
politicians well joining me to discuss
all of this from the campaign for
nuclear disarmament Carol Turner in the
studio also joined by former Major
General of the British Armed Forces Tim
cross down the line and in New York
we're joined by theoretical physicist
Michio Kaku
um Mr kako I will start with you if you
don't mind thank you for making time for
us and I want you to respond to what I
was just saying and the idea that we in
the west don't fully appreciate the
horror of the nuclear bomb like the
Japanese do do you think that's true
I think there's a danger that people in
the West May trivialize nuclear war we
have computer games and we fight War all
the time on a computer screen not
realizing the enormous potential of what
could happen if we unleash nuclear fire
now some people say well is it the
scientist's fault well realize it back
in the 1930s it was widely believed that
Nazi Germany was ahead of us in terms of
developing the nuclear weapons the
greatest atomic scientist of our time
Werner Heisenberg was in charge of the
Nazi atomic bomb project so a naturally
Einstein would write a letter to the
president Roosevelt saying that we have
to start our own atomic bomb project
because well the right the the Germans
are ahead and who wants a Nazi atomic
bomb but after the war it became obvious
that we had Overkill we had more than
enough nuclear weapons to to fight any
adversary right now we have on the order
of 30
000 nuclear weapons enough to destroy
all life on the planet Earth and so we
have to realize the consequences of our
decisions made way back in the 1930s
back then it was it Justified to build
the atomic bomb I think so but to carry
on the war after the after World War II
to create 30 000 tactical and hydrogen
bombs I think was unforgivable you're a
physicist talk to me a little bit about
your connection with nuclear technology
and the journey you've been on because
you've now backed disarmament groups if
I'm correct in thinking
that's correct uh many of my professors
were the ones who built the atomic bomb
uh Philip Morrison for example at MIT
once confided to me that it was his job
to assemble piece by piece much of the
Nagasaki bomb with his bare hands there
was no manual there's no book to put
together a Nagasaki bomb in those days
he did it with his bare hands and of
course he justified dropping the atomic
bomb on Japan he said it helped to win
the war but afterwards he became
anti-nuclear now when I was in high
school I was chosen by an atomic
scientist to work on these things Edward
Teller Edward Teller was my mentor
throughout my high school and college
Years he was the one who pushed forth
the hydrogen bomb a bomb that is a
thousand times more powerful than a puny
Hiroshima bomb and he was the one who
help to build the Arsenal and went head
to head with the Soviet Union and so you
begin to realize there was a split a
split in the scientific Community many
scientists would privately believe in
the work of Oppenheimer who had doubts
about this nuclear proliferation but the
Pentagon was gung-ho in terms of
grabbing at every single nuclear straw
they could get their hands on thank you
for giving us that context Let's cross
now to our other guests joining this
conversation coming to you Tim also
joining us down the line and I bought up
the recent Russian threat it's not the
first and it's certainly probably not
going to be the last unfortunately as a
military man how concerned are you by
the recent Russia threat and do you
think the public is paying enough
attention
I don't think we're paying enough
attention the public in the round it is
a serious threat I think it's pretty
improbable but nonetheless it is
possible and we need to remember that
well mostly when we talk about nuclear
weapons we talk about strategic nuclear
exchange what we used to call in the
Cold War Days mutually assured
destruction and those numbers that the
professor were talking about were very
much a part of that and that you know
the huge numbers that we had in place at
the time there have since been strategic
arms limitation talks but those are
broken down recently but the other end
of the spectrum is tactical nuclear
weapons and these are small relatively
small nuclear weapons that can be fired
from artillery and Rockets and indeed
drop from airplanes and so forth and
they have a an effect on a battlefield
rather than taking out major cities and
so forth with the Strategic nuclear
exchange would be we would be talking
about these are Battlefield weapons that
will destroy you know large numbers of
people over relatively small area but
nonetheless a significant area and
Putin's threat to use them is linked to
the fact that he's not winning the
conventional war in Ukraine he's worried
I think about losing the provinces in
that he's gained so far and the key
issue the one that I think most
psychologically is important to him is
the Crimea if Ukraine looked like they
were going to take retake the Crimea
which from a Russian perspective and I
don't agree with it but nonetheless we
need to understand the Russian
perspective here the Russian perspective
is that Crimea is part of Russia and
therefore if they were to lose Crimea
and things were turning really bad and
the conventional war was not going well
then it is possible that kaputin could
order the use of tactical nuclear
weapons now would his generals can carry
that out what's the chain of command I
mean I know a little bit about it but
the chain of command to actually fire
these weapons you know how robust is
that is another issue altogether as you
say Tim it's sort of almost a concession
at this point that there is a
counter-offensive there is some way to
succeeding look I want to come and bring
Carol into this conversation now she's
been sitting in the studio listening to
this as strategic nuclear exchange or
mutually assured destruction as we
talked about in the past
um when you hear the argument for it
we're currently at War uh what do you
say to the public that you know to
convince them that we don't need nuclear
weapons
I say first of all that these so-called
small tactical nuclear weapons are many
many times more powerful than the atom
bomb dropped on Hiroshima or Nagasaki
and therefore don't be fooled by the
terminology these are developed being
developed by the United States
and by other countries
they the war in Ukraine is actually a
confrontation between two nuclear powers
Russia on the one hand NATO with the
nuclear Armory of the USA behind it on
the other so let us not talk
about continuing the war which is 99 of
information I would say propaganda that
we get on British television and across
Western Europe in fact there is an
incredible danger of the wars
spiraling out of hand
the latest
information which most British people
have not been made aware of is that U.S
nuclear weapons are coming to Britain as
part of the NATO forces in Europe
they're going to be stationed in Lake
and Heath which is about 70 miles north
east of the capital in Suffolk if that
puts us on the front line were they to
be used then the whole of Britain the
whole of the British Isles would be
devastated by it and of course of course
the fact that whether they're used or
not makes us a front line a threat a
front line so my my final sentence is to
everyone who's watching is please be
very very afraid do not listen to the
propaganda that nuclear weapons are
small they will be used in a Battlefield
this is not true so you are very much
obviously reinforcing the idea that we
need to get wise about the real risk of
nuclear weapons I want to come back to
Tim though and talk a little bit about
we do have them they're there in terms
of I know you speak on behalf of
disarmament but Tim when we think about
policy and the way politicians use
nuclear weapons that's a big issue that
is brought up within the movie
Oppenheimer which obviously is based in
real life uh interesting statistics 6 in
10 Americans are uncomfortable with the
president having the sole authority to
authorize the use of nuclear weapons do
you think politicians can be trusted
with nukes and if not who should be
well I don't think anybody could be
trusted with nukes but whether we like
it much or not we live in a Democratic
Society we elect our politicians and
ultimately the other alternative would
be to have the military in charge and
that's not a clever solution either so
I'm afraid we're stuck with the fact
that politicians do have to have the
authority and the responsibility and
therefore the accountability to decide
whether to use these weapons or not now
you know again I I understand what what
the lady is saying and I'm not a great
fan of strategic nuclear weapons at all
but nonetheless we do need to understand
the distinction between these things it
is I'm afraid she's not correct in
saying it is not true that they are
different these are escalatory weapons
that can be used in different ways under
the deterrence strategic deterrence
Theory and so forth but we all used to
know so well back in the Cold War years
but at the end of the day you know again
to focus back in on your question who
else do you want to be in charge of this
we're not going to disinvent these
things they are around what we need to
have in in place is the ability to
ensure that we deter the use of these
weapons by the ability to stand firm
against people like Putin I mean in the
introductory comments by the professor
quite rightly he raised the whole issue
of the threat of Germany having a
nuclear weapon I've got no doubt at all
that if Hitler had access to nuclear
weapons he would have used them in 1945.
so you know we have to recognize and
I've I've been on operations against
people like
um you know milosevic and Saddam Hussein
and all the other hoods who are you know
dangerous nasty people in the world we
cannot be naive about this so it has to
be I think in that at the end of the day
in the hands of politicians now the
command chain and who who gathers around
within the political world to make those
decisions you know that's another issue
must be the prime minister or should it
be the cabinet or you know whomever else
offer the final um thoughts to Dr Kaku
joining us from the US because he set up
this debate so well and gave us that
important context the mentored as you
said by Taylor which of course was a
character well who was personified
within the movie
um look Dr Kaku you think a lot about
the future when you think about the
future from here with regards to the
nuclear threat and how we handle this
strategic nuclear exchange what do you
see
well in the short term of course we have
a theory of deterrence using nuclear
weapons to deter the enemy from nuclear
weapons but I think we have to go beyond
that I think we have to look at the
question of disarmament now we're not
talking about a pie in the sky we're
talking about real life conflicts we
don't want people like Putin to threaten
other people with tactical nuclear
weapons because once it starts how do
you stop it it's easy to start nuclear
aware but how do you stop a nuclear war
once it's in progress once you lose
Washington once you lose Moscow at what
point do you stop so even though a small
tactical exchange could be very bad it
could easily escalate to a full-fledged
consultation with strategic nuclear
weapons and so I think that Beyond
deterrence we have to begin honest
realistic discussions of disarmament or
else we will have more putins in the
future declaring that they will settle
their ancient Grudge matches with
nuclear weapons Dr Carol Tim thank you
all very much for really interesting
discussion
well I bet you're awake now aren't you
uncensored next tonight a cartoon
drawing lots of people have gotten their
thoughts and a Twist about is it all a
storm in a coffee cup we'll be debating
that next
foreign
[Music]
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking
some I don't know you're probably going
to vote me after church
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drunk you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
It's All About Me
it's a joke
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now in case
you've been in a Cupboard all day or
haven't gone on social media let me tell
you that the coffee chain cost of coffee
has caused a funeral following an advert
they sort of put on the side of a van
basically featuring a cartoon of what
appears to be a post-operative
transsexual man now critics who've been
very angry about this online all day say
it's glorifying and celebrating
irreversible surgical procedures for
young women a spokesperson for those
behind this mural from Costa said quote
at Costa Coffee we celebrate the
diversity of our customers team members
and partners we want everyone that
interacts with us to experience the
inclusive environment that we create to
encourage people to feel welcome free
and unashamedly proud to be themselves
the mural in its entirety showcases and
celebrates inclusivity now we're going
to be talking about this now is it
outrageous woke propaganda or just a
storm in a coffee cup who better then to
give us our opinions on this then CEO of
the LGB Alliance Kate Barker and
celebrated lgbtqi plus campaigner Peter
tachel thank you both for making time to
talk about this and I'll just uh if you
don't mind give you my view on it and I
sort of included it within the opening
sort of talk in the show regards nuclear
so you know we've taken her off the ball
here we need some perspective on this
there's fewer other issues like this
drives me absolutely up the wall
um I understand there's important
sensitive debates and discussions to be
had about the trans movement and about
its place in society but I am slightly
exasperated by the attention that this
type of stunt gets and I might concern
is that corporates and companies and
exploiting the experience of trans
people saying that they're being
inclusive but at the same time knowing
that it's just going to generate so much
controversy and conversation around
their brand that they won't be forgotten
about sure some people may cost a coffee
not get their coffee but some people may
well go in and that's successful
marketing in and of itself my fear about
all these things is always is that trans
people haven't been included or
consulted within this debate
um I'm obviously far on probably the
more left and wokey end of this than
some other people on this network as
well but I want to come to you and ask
for your opinion on this
um let's just start with you Kate I mean
well I mean to start with I think it's
actually it's ghoulish and it's
grotesque and and it's really greedy of
Costa imagine thinking what's really
going to make our Tails ring I know the
the mutilation and the misery of girls
who hate their bodies and this isn't
about a trans issue this is about girls
who are opting for bilateral
mastectomies they're having healthy
breast tissue removed and it's not a
niche issue it's not a small issue
before I came on this afternoon I hopped
on to
um GoFundMe and I into the search bar I
put Top surgery and there are 8 649
girls
shaving up hoping planning for Top
surgery GoFundMe is only one platform
there are loads and loads of others so
what we're looking at really is tens and
thousands of girls in the UK
trying to save up money to get this done
now so it's not Niche I I don't think I
like your storm in a coffee cart but I I
don't I don't think it is and I think
it's about vulnerable girls I don't
think it's a transition I think that
adds that adds too much
um heat to the debate I think it's very
much more about
girls who are gender non-conforming and
I would say that a lot of those girls
are tomboys what used to be called
tomboys like like me when I was a kid I
didn't like I didn't like dresses and
pink and I wanted to play football
um and I if I was 12 now
and I saw all this and I saw the
glorification if I was being cheered on
to go ahead and to mutilate myself I
would have just leapt onto that
bandwagon with with
um with both feet I see the point you're
making uh mutilate to me is a strong
word when it's obviously we're talking
about people who are young doing this
and we don't know the person on the cost
of Anne could be 26 but the the core of
the debate is of course that young
people in the in this sort of industrial
complex of breast removal and
augmentation and everything else like
that are being exploited Peter but if
it's voluntary is it mutilation I mean
it's a strong terminology
well first let me say that I think that
the obsession with the Trans issue is
out of all proportion we have more than
seven million people in our Hospital
waiting lists some of them are dying
because they can't get surgery and we're
obsessing over a cartoon on a coffee van
that's absurd priorities but to answer
your point directly
in this country no one can have gender
reassignment surgery before the age of
17 as a minimum in England that's right
let me let me interrupt you let me let
me finish let me you didn't drop
in England not before the age of 17
except if there are exceptional
circumstances but most people
will wait three to five years to get
their first appointment at a gender
identity Clinic then we'll have to have
a series of further appointments usually
between six months and one year apart
and then they have to wear another three
to five years to have the surgery so
it's very rare for anybody to have
surgery before the mid to late 20s and I
know people in their early 30s who are
still waiting having applied 13 years
ago okay so you're saying that the issue
isn't as uh grossly out of proportion or
it's not happening as frequently as some
might think and some people are
struggling at this Kate you had a point
yeah it's actually false that no
children are being operated on the NHS
has highlighted 51
not very many but 51 girls age 16 and 17
who've had mastectomies and I know you
think mutilation is is a bit extreme but
you know those that that's healthy
breast tissue that those operations are
really really serious and there's a
reason why why people like Peter call it
Top surgery because I've heard you
mention it before because it's it's
sanitizes it sounds quite cute and neat
and easy and simple but it isn't it's a
really serious surgery ask any woman
that's had breast cancer what it's like
to have have a mastectomy and to do that
to yourself to health your healthy body
it's irreversible I think it's the only
Silver Lining is that people do have to
wait a long time is there an age at
which you would deem it accept or
somebody to make that decision
themselves our position is that for a
very small minority of people who've had
the proper support proper counseling had
time to think having a surgery a
cosmetic surgery which enables them to
resemble the opposite sex is a good
option for and we hope that would help
them to live a happy life I don't think
it's down to ages except we would say
never ever ever for children it's
absolutely wrong let's listen uh to some
testimony now in fact this is the story
of Chloe Cole she's a d transitioner
27th of July 2023 her 19th birthday
testified to congress with a final
warning that Medical Treatments to
change the gender of confused children
is quite horrific let's take a listen
we need to stop telling children that
puberty is an option puberty is a right
of passage to adulthood not a disease to
be mitigated my childhood was ruined
along with thousands of deep
transitioners that I know through our
networks enough children have already
been victimized by this barbaric
pseudoscience please let me be your
final warning
oh Peter interesting points already
brought up by both of you this evening
and that separating this almost from the
trans discussion because you've got
other things going on here you've got
people as Kate said who prefer to look
like a tomboy you've also got the issue
of age and consent going on here when
you hear Chloe's testimony uh how do you
think that plays into the way the public
are perceiving all this well I'm very
sorry for Chloe that she went through a
bad experience
but she did not go to that experience uh
as far as I'm aware under pressure or in
a short space of time this resulted in
many years of counseling and seeing
Specialists and then she decided to go
ahead with it now I'm sorry that she
regrets it I'm very sorry for her but
there are only less than one percent of
trans people who have gender
reassignment surgery reject a reject or
have regrets about it you know 99 or
almost 99 say it has dramatically
improved the quality of their lives
they're happier more fulfilled
individuals and their families and
friends support that so for most people
Chloe's experience is not typical
gender reassignment surgery is life
enhancing and it does mean a better
quality of life for the people go
through it so I would say Live and Let
Live oh okay so statistically Peter
saying exception to the rule
specifically I mean that's actually
that's simply false we don't have any
data uh for the for the huge influx of
young people who've been having those
kind of surgeries in the past few years
we have no long-term data and that
that's just plucked out of the air that
99 you know that's that's a very
suspicious three major three major
surveys so so what we do have we'd have
no evidence that children particularly
girls are any happier after their
surgery we have a lot of evidence for
example that most children who allowed
to go through adolescence un-medicalized
80 to 90 grow out of their feelings of
dysphoria
so we would always argue that waiting is
best we see what's happened with this
poor girl Chloe I think that in years to
come we're not going to remember the
names of these girls because there's
going to be a flood of them
and do you think that they've been
caught up in a Zeitgeist Peter I mean
returning back to the original uh source
of this conversation Costa Coffee can
you believe it but the way that the
narrative has been pursued by corporates
by companies but also by Society do you
think people are getting caught up in it
teenagers young people influenced by
social media
there may be a tiny element of that but
it's not typical and not the norm the
vast majority of people and I I know
dozens and dozens of trans women I wish
Kate would stop calling them girls
they're not girls they're mature women
often in their 20s 30s and 40s Chloe is
15. yes I just I just explained that I
had sympathy with her but she's in the
United States she's not here here in
this country people have to wait years
typically for General reassignment
surgery from the very first application
to have a gender identity Clinic
appointment it will take 10 or more
years for them to have any surgery
during which time they are counseled and
given support so they've got opportunity
to reconsider and to assess whether
they're making the right decision so the
idea this is rushed or forced on people
is simply false and it's really painful
for those many trans people have to wait
all these years to get the surgery that
will affirm who they truly are and make
them happy I just say that there is
eight and a half thousand young people
most mostly girls who are crowdfunding
for their surgery aren't going through
the NHS I was I was busy on Google today
and I had a look at clinics in London
where you can go and get gender
reassignment surgery and the prices for
it and they are absolutely booming so
the NHS is one thing and there is a long
wait time but people are funding for
surgery themselves and they're going to
clinics which are taking advantage of
people who dislike their own bodies it's
an absolute Scandal the biggest Scandal
we agree we agree and no one should be
rushed into this yeah but no one should
make a swift decision yeah it has to be
thought through very carefully people
have to be counseled they have to be
questioned they have to be given other
options and then if they decide that's
what they want then we should respect
their autonomy and their right to
consent yeah I think that agreement
we've reached and look uh I don't think
we've finished talking about it I think
this will continue to be a hot topic of
debate extraordinarily but this evening
we've learned of course that there's so
many different levels to listen people
involved uh Kate Peter thank you very
much for your views here on uncensored
next tonight we're going to be debating
Elon musk's ongoing Rebrand of Twitter
does x mark the rot or are we all
missing the great man's genius that
coming up next
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
thank you
welcome back to uncensored look they say
what goes up must come down well no one
knows that more than Elon Musk
especially over the past week the
business magnet has been forced by San
Francisco authorities to take down his
giant glowing X sign after local
residents complained it was interrupting
their sleep and it's just the latest
setback for musk's attempts to Rebrand
Twitter and that iconic blue bird symbol
the platform which saw yay West's
account reinstated at the weekend
following an almost eight month ban for
anti-Semitism also faces accusations of
allowing hate speech to go unchecked so
does Elon Musk know what he's doing or
does x mark the rot for this social
media platform I'm joined in the studio
by talk TV contributor Paula Roan Adrian
and down the line from the author and
former Levi brand president to Jennifer
say and the chief strategy officer
rather sorry a router and PR Guru Ian
bear thank you all so much uh look
Jennifer I'll come to you first because
you have uh headed up a much beloved
brand when you saw this Rebrand from
Twitter to X and it's still very much in
process and it's in a very bumpy Rebrand
what have you made of it all
well I'm at the sort of school of
thought from a branding standpoint but
that a brand is what you make of it and
brand uh logos brand meanings that are
expansive and so you know I think what
he's trying to Signal it is that X is
going to be a super app you know like uh
like China's WeChat we don't have
anything like that
um here in America for instance and you
know X is sort of meant to kind of be
Broad and expansive but I think when you
have a brand and a logo and a mark like
Twitter which has to have 90 awareness
at least
um I I feel like the smarter route and
I'm gonna have a Twitter user but I feel
like the smarter route would have been
to keep the existing name and logo and
to expand the meaning with enhanced
product services this feels like a
distraction to me so if I was musk I
would have hired you to give that advice
because I am I really hires me I am a
real Twitter nice nice comeback I am a
real Twitter user I will now an ex-user
hate the Rebrand if I'm being quite
honest I do think musk has slightly lost
his way but I kind of have to hold my
sort of breath here because he is a sort
of Twisted genius you've got to give him
time with these things with Tesla with
everything else he's proved time and
again that he can just make it work but
look let's be honest Ian advertising
revenues down extraordinarily he's got
this huge debt load in the company as
well I don't want to get too much in the
business weeds because it's just what I
like to do uh but also just an x the
letter X for some reason to me it's a
sort of totemose fragile masculinity am
I going too far
well look it X is Elon musk's personal
brand I mean before he was the
monolithic billionaire
force of nature that he is he had this
thing called x.com that he sold to
PayPal and that really led to to so much
of what would follow for musk so this is
just him putting his own personal brand
on it and yeah we could talk about the
relative brand awareness of the Twitter
name versus X
but the biggest brand of all here is
Elon Musk and and what he decided to do
10 days ago
is really the end of what's been going
on for a year you spoke to the declining
ad revenues there's been a huge turnover
and shift in the base the base has
become a little more politically skewed
actually a lot more politically skewed
than it formally was so this is just the
conclusion of a process and I completely
agree I mean now what we're going to see
here's the next step right there's a new
CEO uh Lindy acarino who if nothing else
is doing a really good job of mouth
piecing musk's Vision as something that
she buys into and now we have to see
what x becomes but Elon Musk is the
biggest brand we're talking about here
not Twitter yeah and the question is Jen
I suppose is can people back the brand
musk because you know yes he is a
business genius and he's done a lot uh
but he's not that popular
um he's very controversial you know
famously he's got sort of 10 children by
many different women which doesn't
really get a lot of women on side also
he's not really got San Francisco on
side of the motor which of course is the
corporate headquarters for that company
he's having this battle about this giant
X logo but it's sort of all a bit Gotham
city-esque isn't it it's sort of like
he's this megalomaniac genius falling
out with the the authorities there what
do you make of it or do you think people
will gather behind musk laggy and
suggesting
you know at the end of the day they're
using Twitter
um and so they have to like that product
and feel like it adds value to their
lives they're not gonna use it I think
they're not gonna use it because of him
you know I do think his form of
provocation used to make him very
popular and now he's fallen out of favor
and certainly has a media kind of coming
at him aggressively what I find ironic
and I am a former San Francisco and I
lived there for over 30 years very near
the Twitter headquarters I find it you
look he should have gotten the right
permits but again that's his kind of bad
boy Persona he does what he wants
um he didn't get the right permits he's
got to take the sign down people
complained I I find it sort of
unbelievable that the people had the
energy and gumption to complain about a
lighted sign but not the hundreds if not
thousands of people that are dying on
the Streets of San Francisco
um who are homeless mentally ill and
drug addicted right in front of Twitter
that is where they sort of congregate
some of the law largest encampments are
right there they can't get the energy to
push back and try to help those people
but they sure did find a lot of energy
to get that sign taken down it says a
lot really interesting context from you
know former resident of the Native as
well that you can tell us that because
in the UK especially we might not get
the full picture of it and it is Bleak
when you put it like that and that he is
trying to develop what we're going to
call a Chinese super app an app called
WeChat in China where they integrate
payment systems and business items
within the sort of social networking and
the media as well let Ian quickly before
I get to Paula in the studio do you
think a super app is something that the
world is going to embrace
well certain parts of the world already
have and I don't think that his vision
for a super app is that Divergent from
necessarily what Jeff Bezos is building
with his many Amazon Holdings and and
you know if if Apple makes a bold move
in the future for a Content acquisition
let's say a Netflix is in play or a
Disney is in play uh you can see others
marching down that path this has been
his stated vision from day one the
question more is what he's going to do
with it he's great at setting Vision his
history speaks to his ability to
marriage marry that Vision to creation
of enormous wealth and capital
his brand has lost some luster he's lost
some credibility a number of his stock
prices have have gotten crushed uh with
questions about his ability to lead
here's his chance to see through perhaps
his biggest Vision
um
I mean we we tolerated Facebook renaming
themselves meta to support a bigger
Vision before that Google became
alphabet to support a bigger vision
it can work that there is precedent for
it look I want to come to Paula in the
studio now and talk a little bit about
hate speech because that is where some
of the brand luster has been lost as Ian
just put it especially for me when I'm
using the app you know you can just feel
and you can see that there is more and
uh there's an organization called the
center for countering digital hate
they've run a number of reports to find
out how much hate is on the platform and
they've come out and said uh
extraordinary amounts and Twitter is
failing or X is failing to take action
gets 99 out of 100 Twitter blue accounts
that have been reported for hate speech
violations musk is going to counter Sue
because he says your methodology was
wrong uh when you think about this from
a legal perspective because you are a
legal mind
um these platforms for years I said
we're not Publishers but it seems musk
is heading towards the publishing route
I I think he's he he's heading towards a
very dangerous area actually where he's
going to consistently encounter the law
and consistently encounter
um clients
we can't call them tweets anymore you
know users social media users who are
going to be upset with what he is
essentially promoting because he is
providing this platform that will allow
for for hate speech now now
interestingly as I understand it the
lawsuit has been lodged it was lodged on
Monday in the Californian court and
where that's going to take us I don't
know but we have to remember don't we
that it's okay to criticize a company
it's okay to criticize someone if they
are not acting in a way that we think is
appropriate or responsible and when we
talk about freedom of speech we're not
talking about the the right to have your
say we're talking about the right not to
hate we're talking about the right not
to publish that hate and I do worry for
Elon that he's going down that dangerous
road now to be fair to him we had ye who
had been banned from the platform twice
to be fair and he's only just come back
on in the last eight months so let's see
what happens with that
um Trump was also banned and although he
was offered an opportunity to come back
he said no thank you he's got his own
now he's got his own now he's doing his
own thing
um but I do worry that Elon Musk thinks
that offering somebody a platform from
freedom of speech is suddenly going to
mean that he is going to be overrun with
with lots of new new members I don't
think that's going to work do you think
he underestimated the challenge of free
speech completely yeah completely and
he's going to pay for that he will and
he is well literally paying for it it
seems at the moment we'll see how this
latest lawsuit goes let Ian and Jennifer
thank you very much for joining us
giving us your insights Paula in the
studio as well we'll keep you here uh
thanks for a great chat on Santa's next
tonight it is World youth day and in
honor of it we're looking at some family
pics do you know who this is
you can guess we'll reveal after the
break
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think there's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail start working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for at what appears to
be an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories way TK
team that would make her a better
princess of wealth because you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him
the conservi party can certainly win the
next election can we yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
Rest our souls
thank you
let it roll
[Music]
producing oil the knock-on effect is far
larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
you're probably going to vote me after
I've done this stuff
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about yeah
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
It's All About Me that's a joke
[Music]
coming up on the talk a Crackdown on
crime with repeat offenders given
mandatory jail sentences which is how
cool does he promotes the government's
shake-up of alcohol taxes and ITV has
approached Boris Johnson to star in I'm
a celebrity get me out of here that's
all at nine o'clock
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to peers uncensored still
with me talk TV contributor pull around
Adrian and joining us in the studio talk
TV presenter Richard Tice now excuse me
just still shuddering from the concept
of seeing Boris Johnson in that jungle
shower
[Laughter]
this country is a sucker for punishment
look look we've got you in to have a bit
of fun because we've covered some really
serious topics so far nuclear
disarmament and the rest of it um and
it's been a really big week for animal
stories don't work with animals and
children that's the uh common saying in
television well let's take a look at
this animal this is from Japan a man who
identifies as a border collie Japanese
man transformed himself into a canine
after forking out more than fourteen
thousand dollars for a custom-made
collie costume it goes by Toco online
and says it's his dream to be an animal
and I don't know about YouTube but when
I saw this first on Twitter actually I
thought wow that just looks like a
border collie I'm quite impressed I mean
that's serious attention to detail Paula
incredible intentions detail and can I
say it looks like hard work I mean if
anyone has taken the downward dog
position in yoga that is not something
that you can hold for particularly long
so a God note I mean he went for a walk
Rosanna in there that's that's it looks
a little bit stiff doesn't I mean
he's very stiff or he's got arthritis or
something because I mean he is not he's
not moving well is he yeah dog Richard I
have actually
I think I do believe it or not I do a
bit of yogurt I was doing yoga last week
on holiday actually yeah in the sunshine
get a border collie outfit for uh
Richard next week
I mean to be fair to be fair to him I I
don't think he's so much identifies as a
border collie what he says is that he
loves uh fairy animals he's very much in
love with animals and he likes to
replicate them and and this is just one
of the many that he has dressed up I've
got better things to do with fourteen
thousand dollars
this is
loads
come on it is it is a sort of movement
isn't it fairies and like you said you
know it can have sexual connotations or
it cannot some people are very innocent
about it some people I mean this we're
just watching a guy walking around as a
dog well we're being we're being very
innocent about it because you know
fairies are all about dressing up and
it's all it's all about animation as
well it's not just about the dressing
art and so it's aching to your child
wanting to be Luke Skywalker or your
child wanting to be Barbie yeah exactly
well talking of children let's move on
to another very innocent topic I promise
you it is World youth day uh that is
today we love a sort of segment Peg to
some sort of day this youth day to sort
of bring together people to talk about
their youth but also to deepen their
religious Faith that's what this day is
all about but we of course thought we'd
Market with some funny pictures show you
what we all look like as kids let's see
what Richard Tice looked like as a child
oh look at that very very sweet a
picture of Innocence Richard picture of
Innocence there we are I mean what could
possibly go wrong what would your
parents have said about you as a child
oh I think I might have been a little
bit of a rogue actually I think I was a
bit noisy yeah the bow tie gives it away
I think it does yes maybe a little bit
sort of individualistic yeah
uh Paula let's let's see what you look
like as a child dear
oh look at that
I can see the eyes photogenic looking
into the camera yeah
that picture was was first portrait
taken when we
when we're so I am
and I would probably been about five
years old in that picture and we lived
in a bed set in one room we were a
family of four
um but my mum really wanted to mark that
occasion and so we got somebody in to
take some photos of this so you remember
that we're having oh that's especially
coming the dress I was wearing was a
dress that I wore on the plane from
Jamaica it was you know a very special
outfit it was red my favorite color
um I had my red ribbons in my hair I
remember everything about it that's
absolutely lovely thank you so much for
sharing that look we've also got a game
for you uh again just to lighten the
mode and keep it on the youth topic
we've got some pictures of famous people
from when they were children we want you
to guess who they are just from the
pictures alone panel game for Richard
and Paula let's get the first picture
come on Richard to do at home as well
who is this Rishi oh straight okay very
good yeah yeah there you go Bing next
who do you we have
oh
Boris
oh Donald
let's see what we've got number three
that's obvious come on Elon that's Elon
isn't it absolutely is yeah Elon Musk
that goes to Paula and the next one
fourth who have we got here this is a
famous picture Richard I would expect
you to maybe recognize I'm I'm not that
old
I think this person's the same age as
you oh
um next clue give us a clue
I think I preferred him when he was
younger
first of all the one we showed our order
oh God would you say it's a girl or a
boy wow okay
yeah it's not you is it you it's not me
it's not you
I mean it's you but in male form I can
show we were close
we could show you a picture of me as a
child very different that's me very
serious wannabe oh deeply serious very
thoughtful yeah yeah when we lived in
Wales uh back a day I think it was about
four years old it's been great fun
having you both Richard and Paulie
really lightened the mood after some
very uh heavy topics this evening I
think you won the game Paula absolutely
of course three or four yeah I'm not
very good at that
and you can send your apologies to Piers
Morgan in a stuffed envelope leave it in
a dressing room
pass it on to him that is it from me
tonight whatever you're up to make sure
it is uncensored and join us back here
tomorrow night and stay with us here on
talk TV good night
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you